back in Tokyo dr. Naoki Suzuki oversees
the Assembly of high resolution images
from Lubas CT scan images that will tell
her tale from the inside out
for waiting those results dan Fisher
takes time to consider Lyuba from
another angle there's a side of science
that we often think about is the hard
side the careful scrutiny of ideas the
detailed evaluation of backgrounds
circumstances and that's an important
sign without it we couldn't have the
trust that we have in our results but
there's another side of science that is
perhaps the more creative side it has to
do with the where ideas come from you
realize is that they really come from
sort of free associations an open mind
and one of the things that we have to
then do as scientists is practice a sort
of relaxation of sort of clearing of the
mind a sort of attempt to make some
connection with the phenomena that we're
studying this is not anything that's
that's magic it's it's something that
happens differently for every scientist
dan lets his mind drift back to the
Siberian steppe 40,000 years ago
baby Yuba might have been only a few
months old traveling with the mammoth
herd under the watchful eye of her
mother she would mimic the gestures of
her family but would not yet be
coordinated or mature enough for a diet
of plants
Luber would still be dependent on her
mother's milk
today baby lubbers extraordinary
preservation could lead to new
discoveries about mammoths behavior and
Dan hopes she's ready to share her Ice
Age secrets secrets he'll pursue here
and in the field when he follows her
trail back to the tundra
you